vivimos en un mundo en el que el
consumismo se ha apoderado de la
sociedad vivimos en un tiempo donde
mientras algunos disfrutamos de grandes
privilegios hay otros que no tienen que
comer en costa rica se desperdician 5000
toneladas de comida al año esto podría
satisfacer las necesidades nutricionales
de 220 mil individuos hace
aproximadamente 3 años mi compañera
maría paula mora y yo descubrimos que la
cafetería de nuestro colegio dispensaba
bandejas de comida totalmente aptas para
el consumo humano y decidimos encontrar
una manera para la escuela cual la
cafetería de nuestro colegio pudiera
dispensar de su comida de una manera más
servicial y después de horas de idear
llegamos a la siguiente propuesta un
grupo de voluntarios llegaría a la
cafetería del colegio empacar ya la
comida y la distribuiría a personas
necesitadas dentro
en nuestra comunidad sin embargo cuando
sacamos una reunión con los gerentes de
la cafetería muy emocionados no llevamos
ni por el segundo slide y ya habían
rechazado nuestra propuesta resulta que
de acuerdo con el código legal
costarricense cualquier persona u
organización que donen comida tiene
completa responsabilidad sobre los
productos donados hasta el momento en el
que estos son ingeridos lo que por
supuesto era un problema muy grande para
la cafetería de nuestro colegio pero no
sólo eso en ese momento nos dimos cuenta
de que este problema iba mucho más allá
que la cafetería de nuestro colegio este
tecnicismo legal afectaba a cualquier
compañía grande o pequeña que quisiera
donar comida en costa rica entonces
empezamos a ver cómo podíamos llevar
esta pequeña propuesta a un nivel
nacional y empezamos a investigar cómo
se maneja esto en otros países nos
encontramos con la ley del buen
samaritano en eeuu entre otras leyes en
suiza y en francia
pero lo más importante de todo fue que
hablamos con miembros de esta industria
quién costa rica para validar que
efectivamente la conclusión a la que
habíamos llegado con la cafetería de
nuestro colegio era un problema aquí en
costa rica y era ese tecnicismo legal lo
que estaba impidiendo una cadena de
donación estable y dentro de esta
investigación nos encontramos con la
oficina de participación ciudadana una
rama de la asamblea legislativa por la
cual cualquier ciudadano menor o mayor
de edad puede presentar una iniciativa
ante el gobierno y en ese momento nos
percatamos de que era nuestra
responsabilidad como ciudadanos
costarricenses presentar una iniciativa
que fuera protegerá a todos los
benefactores a la hora de donar comida y
así nació el proyecto de ley 20.207 el
cual proyecte a los 16 años con mi
compañera maría paula actualmente el
proyecto se encuentra en la comisión de
asuntos sociales
a legislativa y se está trabajando con
un bufete internacional para adaptar y
presentar una versión similar del
proyecto en otros países de
centroamérica que tienen este mismo
problema irónicamente la pregunta que
más veces me han hecho con respecto a mi
proyecto no tiene que ver con hambre
tampoco con desperdicio ni tampoco con
la responsabilidad a la hora de donar
comida amigos familiares mentores
inclusive diputados con los que he
trabajado insisten en preguntarme por
qué redacte un proyecto de ley y bueno
donde yo brinco muy emocionado a
contarles que trabaje con la cafetería
de mi colegio y que me di cuenta que
había un tema de responsabilidad a la
hora de donar comida usualmente suelen
interno firme como en esta parte de la
historia y me vuelven a preguntar pero
porque se trata de un proyecto de ley y
ya la segunda vez que me preguntan logro
entender que no me están preguntando de
qué trata el proyecto de ley o por qué
se redactó a este proyecto de ley
específicamente sino porque yo como
estudiante
redacte una iniciativa legal porque yo
como estudiante de colegio estuve
interactuando con el sistema
gubernamental de nuestro país y analizar
la retrospectiva esta y otras de las
situaciones pruebas que pase con este
proyecto me quedan claras tres cosas la
primera es que hay una gran mala
interpretación de lo que significa el
concepto de la democracia la segunda es
que la política tiene una connotación
sumamente negativa especialmente en la
población joven y la tercera es que
hemos perdido la fe en el gobierno
hacer y yo me pregunto cómo está óptima
plataforma del liderazgo que en realidad
la política se ha convertido en este
sistema tan mediocre que tenemos hoy en
día y con estas tres cosas en mente hace
aproximadamente un año estuve analizando
diferentes currículums cuando estaba
aplicando las universidades y me di
cuenta de algo muy curioso las
universidades hoy en día están tan
enfocadas en construir buenos políticos
que han dejado el liderazgo atrás esto
que ven detrás mío fue el caso del 90
por ciento de los currículums que
analice nos enseñan a comprender el
sistema a escribir y expresarlos
persuasivamente nos enseñan a hablar en
público a analizar da para sin embargo
yo me pregunto qué pasó con los valores
del liderazgo qué pasó con el carisma
qué pasó con la innovación que ha pasado
con el trabajo en equipo
qué pasó con la capacidad de escuchar
las ideas de otros porque por más buen
político una persona sin estas
capacidades nunca será un buen líder y
nunca será un buen gobernador
hoy vengo al escenario de té de
inspirada buenas propuestas que se han
hecho en la plataforma internacional que
pueden posicionar a costa rica como un
líder en asuntos internacionales
vengo empoderada porque creo que así
todos nos unimos y empezamos a trabajar
juntos con el sistema podemos llegar a
grandes cosas y recuperar esta óptima
plataforma del líder algo que queda
claro que hemos perdido
el 2017 me invitaron a mí a mi compañero
a un seminario de la organización para
la alimentación y la agricultura de las
naciones unidas- más conocida como la
fao y nos mandaron invitación a través
del colegio entonces el colegio muy
humildemente nos pidió que fuéramos en
uniforme y dónde llegamos mi compañera y
yo en uniforme con la chupaba casi que
con lonchera de colores a esta reunión
donde todos los otros delegados estaban
en saco y corbata pasamos por una pena
horrible pero bueno después de todo esto
vemos donde se nos acerca un delegado y
nos dice ay que dicha que las encuentro
ustedes me podrían servir un vaso de
agua claro
el delegado había pensado que éramos dos
a de canal del programa y no es el hecho
que nos haya pedido un vaso de agua
porque yo y mi compañera con mucho gusto
liberamos servido un vaso de agua es el
hecho de que este delegado estaba
limitando nuestra capacidad para
satisfacer sus necesidades en vez de
decirnos bueno porque no nos tomamos
este vaso de agua
vamos a ver cómo podemos resolver este
problema que es lo que estamos aquí
sentados tratando de hacer hoy y bueno
al final de este seminario se llegaron a
diferentes conclusiones en los
diferentes ámbitos y en el ámbito legal
a la conclusión a la que se llegó fue
exactamente lo que el proyecto de ley
que yo y mi compañera habíamos propuesto
hace un año decía entonces nos dieron la
oportunidad de compartir el proyecto y
en eso vemos donde se nos vuelve a
acercar el mismo delegado ya está bills
súper apenado y nos dice bueno estoy
seguro que en 10 años voy a ser yo al
que nos va a estar sirviendo ustedes un
vaso de agua y cuántas historias porque
creo que refleja muy bien nuestro
comportamiento con el sistema político
insistimos en pedirle cosas para
incrementar nuestra comunidad menos
impuestos en mejor infraestructura vial
entre otras cosas lo que está bien sin
embargo nos rehusamos atrás
ahora con el sistema
no le pidamos un vaso de agua unámonos
propongamos trabajemos juntos luchemos
para recuperar esta óptima plataforma de
liderazgo y nunca neguemos su potencial
hagamos de costa rica- un líder en
asuntos internacionales hoy yo les
pregunto cuál es su idea que vale la
pena difundir muchas gracias